the towers sang
and you cried
[Music]
hey folks take two doctor who review and
it is the first of
two christmas specials that i need to
get through before i can get to series
10.
boy that was a long stretch of time
before they gave us like proper episodes
again
anyways the husbands of river
song this one is always one that i've
had
kind of mixed feelings about um
and whenever i say of mixed feelings
about something
it can mean one of a few different
things sometimes it means that
you know there's elements that are good
but there's nitpicky things that are
bugging me or sometimes it means that
there's actually very clear delineations
of
this whole chunk i don't like as much in
this whole chunk i do
this kind of falls under the former
although it would be an
overstatement for me to say i dislike
the front end
i just don't like it as much largely
because it falls into what a lot of the
christmas specials do and no i'm not
wearing the christmas hat for this one
because
well christmas barely enters into it
it's
really just the just the antlers that he
has at the very front
of the thing and there's some christmas
carols at the beginning
it doesn't bug anyone else that 5 000
years in the future they're still
singing the same christmas carols
like there's been no new ones and like
they haven't even like
had the lyrics alter naturally over time
as
language has evolved or you know it got
mistranslated somewhere i don't know
anyways
totally random nitpick that does not
matter boy that gets us off to a good
start doesn't it
now part of what i don't love about the
front end is just the tone of the thing
because it's going for that lighter
goofier tone that a lot of the
christmas specials go for and that more
often than not rubs me the wrong way
in doctor who uh the music doesn't help
like look i love murray gold when he's
on point but when whenever an episode is
light he just gets this
very goofy music cues that
i really don't take to because they did
they feel like
just a a half a centimeter away from
just being
punctuating jokes directly in that
manner and
like dude if it's funny i'll laugh i
don't need the music to tell me it's
funny
so that that always bothers me
but we open with the doctor meeting
nardole and for as much as i like
nardole and i like nardole a lot
i don't like him in this and his
introduction doesn't work for me i think
a lot of it just has to do with he
doesn't
yet have the rapport with the doctor
that i
love later on largely being that nardole
just kind of is frequently fed up and
irritated with the guy
um here he's much whinier
he's much more oh
about everything i'm like that that gets
all dang
quick so that that's a rough start
we get river and rivers fun um
and rivers always been fun but i i feel
like
later appearances they tried to turn her
almost into a substitute jack
harkness in terms of the level of
frivolity they tried to inject into her
and it's it's honestly a little
much and i think that's kind of on
display here
i think she works best when you know you
get the sense that she is having fun
but she's still you know she's not
overly cavalier about everything
here she's got that going on a little
bit
it it comes together better on the
latter end but
we will get there so
our main villain here is king hydraflax
which is a head currently detached from
a cyborg body that kind of has its own
i was going to say agenda that's not
quite right its own thought processes
on what should be going on and how
things are going to work from here
i don't know the actor who plays the
head of hydraflax
and whenever he's not shouting
he's good he's quite good actually he's
got a line
that i love there's a little exchange he
has with the doctor
a king does not endanger his people for
no reason you're endangering them now
i'm
cross moments like that i'm like oh this
is great but then
so much of what he's doing just devolves
into him shouting stop them
restrain them attack them like oh for
god's sake
dude aside from daleks
nobody's personality should be shouts a
lot
because shouting honestly drowns out
whatever personality you have
it doesn't work as a substitute so
he he doesn't always work for me
for a fair chunk of the thing
i do like how excited the doctor gets
at the idea that he gets to step into
the tardis as if it's his first time
and really overdo
the it's bigger on the inside thing
the like the the beat itself is fine but
it's his
joy in getting to do it that's that's
what sells that moment
overall things start clicking into place
one much more once they get
to the ship with all of the very bad
people
and the uh the restaurant
and you know they're being waited on by
this scummy little blue
uh mater d uh sort of guy
who his first dance and
and you know are you having him for
dinner
oh well i'll have the chef prepare him
like that's the kind of
the kind of place this is and the kind
of person he is and then
you know the doctor still kind of
waiting for river to
recognize him and realizing that she
doesn't
and then it sets up the turning point
where things
really start to work in this episode
once it truly locks into the emotional
connection of the doctor and river as
opposed to just
the adventuring of them then it really
starts to click
and when she has her whole thing where
she basically gets questioned like you
love the doctor yes i do
and he loves you and he'll come and
rescue you and she says no he won't
you are the woman who loves the doctor
yes i am i've never denied it
but whoever said he loved me back and
they scared her like she's not lying
she honestly doesn't
think that he loves her
but she's i'm not sure if okay with that
is the right word but she is
resigned to that she has accepted that
that traveling with the doctor
being involved with him the way that she
is
is enough and
feeling loved back doesn't have to be
part of the equation
and i love that she goes off on this
whole thing
and you know he's right there
and when she realizes that she's trying
to cover
for herself and the doctor rips her for
but it's just
it's really sweet and it's touching
watching her realize that it's him
and him seeing her express that
she doesn't think he loves her back
and then there's just the
the fun of oh got her i love her line
it's one of the
best fu lines in doctor who
where she says oh well there's the
meteor strike what meteor strike
warning incoming meteor
i'm an strike from the future i
dug you up oh
oh that's so good i love that line
so much and then they go to derylium
and i really there's something i
i hadn't taken particular notice of this
element before
it's not like i didn't well no i had
forgotten that this happened
but there's something exceptionally
sweet
about the doctor taking this diamond
that river has been doing all this
nonsense for and giving it to
this guy who's just a nice guy
just seems like a nice guy says hey you
should build a restaurant here
and that creates the restaurant
and he comes to make a reservation they
say well we'll have a reservation for
the balcony in four years
great i'll be right i'll come back and
the lengths that he goes to to give her
this last night and
you know one could argue that it's not
really lengths it's what he it's what
always happened because he already knew
there was a restaurant there it just
maybe he didn't always know that he
caused it to be built or whatever but
that
he's gonna put in the work
to ensure that this is as perfect
as he can make it for what he knows is
there last night together
and what she comes to realize is their
last night together
and i love her line
happy ever after doesn't mean forever
it just means time because i think
that's
the cynical mind says happily ever after
is nonsense and a lie
because nothing ever lasts forever
so i like the idea that you get to claim
that you had a happily ever after
even if it's not forever it doesn't have
to be forever to be a happily ever after
and then it ends with those words and
they lived happily ever after and the
ever after blows away and then
they lived blows away and it's just
happily it's just really nice
once it gets the obligatory christmas
stuff out of the way
once it goes through what is a decent
enough little adventure for the doctor
and river and
gets them to derylium
that's where this is really sweet and
just to come back to the
the diamond in the restaurant i love
that
not only is the doctor ensuring that the
restaurant gets built but it's through
an act of kindness
that feels really appropriate especially
for this doctor as well
so once this thing hits about the
halfway mark maybe a little bit further
in
i love it front half i could really take
or leave
but i'll re-watch the back end of this
and be very happy to
so that's the husbands of river song
you re-watched it lately what'd you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a bunch of stuff to do
like share subscribe i have a patreon
that is what is currently paying the
bills ensuring that this entire
operation
gets to keep going and uh
in addition to that i have merch and
social media links bunch of stuff in the
descriptions
check them out or don't end of the day
you're the council i am just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um